yeah here comes walker bueller he's
taking the ball to another big game
as he tries to in conjunction with the
padres pitch the dodgers
into a game 163 tomorrow
good morning good afternoon and good
night and on three pitches bueller has a
strikeout to open the dead
fielder struck out peterson on three
pitches
he gets adamas on four
early in this game we see the life to
his fastball we also see the late break
to his breaking ball
goes to it again and gets his third
strike out of the first inning
peterson adamus and garcia a team up
against brett anderson here to open up
game 162. i figure he's not going to be
out there very long not until the league
championship series at the earliest we
know that much
chance for two and the brewer is able to
turn it here in the first inning you see
a lot of those with brett anderson out
on the hill
got that ground ball special and we are
through one no score
taken for strike three
each of the first four outs of the game
via the strikeout
fouled into the glove the fifth
strikeout for mueller
and this one
into left field the base hits gonna go
all the way to the wall tyrone taylor
rounding second and he'll hold there
he strikes him out as well the bottom
falls out of a breaking ball and walker
mueller has six strikeouts through two
yondel gustavi now in to take over in
the second inning for brett anderson
yeah we saw him on friday against the
dodgers first game of the series inning
in two thirds
he looked three earned runs
center field
jbj he's got it
and a nice quick inning for
gustave head to the third no score
[Music]
and he quickly
sets gustave down his seventh k
again he hasn't struck out more than
five in a game since august
he at least puts it in play
smith with a running throw and muncie
and payne as peterson reaches
oh
no
the throw is into the runner
muncie tried to tag him
hurts his wrist he is down on his back
as muncie the fourth leading home run
hitter in the national league is coming
out of the game and he is holding
that wrist
you get me in three different ways right
now
fastball ripped up the middle backhand
trey turner one throw and pujos there to
dig it out
immediately involved in the game
trey turner a tremendous play in another
scoreless inning for beulah beat the
cardinals yesterday the brewers have a
five-game lead
dealer strikes out that will end the
third inning gustave
consecutive one two three innings out of
the bullpen for milwaukee we just saw
him that was with the dodgers and has
been able to contribute and have a
good success out of the bullpen and this
one ripped all the way to the base of
the wall for teles and he is digging for
second base and he's going to get in
there standing up so a lead off double
lead off double for milwaukee
that brings up garcia
and this one fair ball down the right
field line
and celez will score for milwaukee
and the brewers surprised the dodgers
here in walker bueller it's one to
nothing it is a weirdly quiet five in
here
that muncie injury took his life out of
the building and another one-two pitch
to omar narvaez
got him this time
eight strikeout of the game one away
0-2
did he go he did and walker bueller able
to limit the damage to just one
remarkable nine k's through four innings
and now the offense tries to get going
in a one-nothing game
here's the three two
and he got him
wow
beauty that's a big app to get him
dodgers keeping an eye on the scoreboard
giants keeping an eye on the scoreboard
and the infield pop goes to telez
the fourth inning over now for los
angeles we head to the fifth
we got ready to go on camera today
is vogelback
takes strike three builder with another
his tenth one shy of a season high
already
he's matched at a season high with 11
strikeouts halfway home in a one-nothing
game
[Applause]
[Music]
slow roller maurice
and a nice scoop by telez for the outs
how slick has he been at first base my
goodness
some kind of soft hands by rowdy teles
to be able to pick that
good play by ariz had to get rid of it
quickly
it loaded up here in a one-nothing game
for mookie betts
3-1 this game is tied at one pacer's
loading rock for murky bets
radio second bets it first
right side race to first it is won by
seger with the ball loose and the
dodgers take their first lead of the day
everybody get a head start here there
they go here it comes turtle pulls one
of the air deep left field way back in a
grand slam
on a day where he'll be crowned
[Applause]
hit of the day it'll drive home will
smith and send taylor to third it's 7-1
he gets three strikeouts in a scoreless
seventh inning
and we stretch in the regular season
finale dodgers up by a bunch
[Music]
mike trout put pujols together he ended
up getting ohtani but they have had a
hard time staying healthy
on the other side of town pujols goes
down swinging good inning for hater good
tune-up for him for the post season
san francisco's up 11-4 in their game
this one hit well right field
and off the wall
here comes
adamus
and rowdy toles his second double of the
game
that is so true
this one hit well to right lux leaps
can't make the catch
to leslie trot home
and the brewers have a couple of runs
here escobar a pinch hit rbi double
grand slam from trey turner his second
one this weekend alex baby turning on a
ball deep right field that one's gone
beatty with a three for three finish to
the regular season kept with a three-run
home run
so the guru's down to their last out
on the hands popped into short right
field
and that will do it
the dodgers match the franchise record
with 106 wins in 2021
you